[Música]
nuevo bloquea economía en directo
américa vamos a empezar a luís méndez en
argentina porque la cámara diputado pero
el acuerdo alcanzado entre el gobierno y
el fondo monetario internacional así es
raúl fueron cerca de 14 horas de debates
en la sede del parlamento y ahora la
iniciativa pasará al senado donde
también será votada de acuerdo con un
comunicado de la cámara de diputados el
acuerdo se aprobó con 202 votos a favor
37 en contra y 13 abstenciones entre
quienes rechazaron la iniciativa estuvo
un sector de la izquierda argentina que
argumenta que el nuevo programa de
facilidades extendidas supondrá un
ajuste que recaerá en la clase
trabajadora la iniciativa sólo autoriza
al ejecutivo a realizar operaciones de
crédito con el fondo monetario
internacional para poder afrontar los
vencimientos con este organismo entre
este año y el 2024 todo ello derivado
del acuerdo stand by firmado en el año
2018 el nuevo programa incluye entre
otros aspectos una reducción gradual del
déficit fiscal primario estableciendo
entre otras cosas recortes a los
subsidios energía
pero los ciudadanos no han tomado de la
mejor manera esta situación recordemos
que para una parte de los argentinos la
imposición de políticas económicas por
parte del organismo fueron las causantes
de una de las peores crisis a principios
de la década del 2000 escuchemos
nuestros escribanía al servicio de
ratificar este acuerdo y es un acuerdo
verdaderamente de entrega de ajuste y de
sometimiento del país cuando decimos del
país sabemos estas asma estamos hablando
de los trabajadores de los sectores
populares de los barrios de la gente de
abajo por un chiste contrario lo dice y
seguimos en nuestro continente porque en
pocas horas de gabriel boric se tomará
posesión de la presidencia de chile
cuáles son los retos que afrontará el
nuevo mandatario materia económica raúl
de acuerdo con algunos especialistas los
principales retos del nuevo mandatario
serán sortear la inflación y mantener el
crecimiento económico del país si
revisamos su propuesta en materia
económica durante la campaña por el
centro la misma en un rediseño de los
subsidios laborales el cual hace énfasis
en el trabajo femenino también establece
una reforma tributaria que entre otras
cosas y si toda la propuesta va
orientada a un esfuerzo mayor de las
personas con más altos ingresos también
propone el financiamiento para el y la
innovación y una minería adaptada a los
desafíos del futuro pero el programa
entre otras cosas también se orienta al
fortalecimiento del sector turismo que
será clave de acuerdo a su visión en un
nuevo modelo de desarrollo económico el
establecimiento de un nuevo marco de
relaciones laborales estableciendo un
incremento escalonado del salario mínimo
que partirá desde los 400 mil pesos
chilenos o unos 500 dólares en su primer
año adicionalmente pólit se compromete a
no alterar ningún acuerdo comercial de
manera unilateral pero si propone
actualizar algunos aspectos estos son
los datos con los que se encontrara
boris al iniciar su mandato una tasa de
inflación anual de 78 por ciento un
desempleo que se ubicó entre noviembre
de 22.021 y enero de 2022 en 78 por
ciento y un crecimiento de 2022 estimado
entre 1.5 y 1.26 2.25 y 2.5 de acuerdo
con el banco central y 3.5 que ha
señalado el gobierno hablamos de otros
dos temas louis porque china culminó
asamblea popular que conclusiones dejó
en materia económica pero no varió los
anuncios pero uno que más llamó la
atención fue el que la nación creará
unos 13 millones de empleos para este
año adicionalmente ese país prevé un
crecimiento en torno al 55 por ciento
que el gobierno manifiesta de ambicioso
por otro lado para ayudar a las empresas
del gobierno pero alguna reducción de
impuestos y tarifas y en ghana los
panaderos de ese país se ven afectados
por el aumento de la inflación una
situación que se presenta por los
problemas en la cadena de suministros
que están derivados entre otras cosas
por la pandemia de kobe 19 y la
depreciación de la moneda en febrero la
inflación del país alcanzó el 15.7 por
ciento previo a la invasión de ruso
ucrania los precios de los cereales
entre ellos el trigo han aumentado por
ello han generado problemas en las
panaderías que han tenido que disminuir
la cantidad de sus productos o venderlos
a un precio elevado y hablamos ahora de
la cifra el día que nos quedó bien tiene
que ver con el 20 por ciento que es la
estimación de acuerdo con la fao que se
incrementarán
los alimentos este año debido a la
crisis entre la rusa y el cráneo louis
gracias por toda la información
económica de hoy viernes feliz se de fin
de semana para ustedes vamos directos a
parís ya está natalia lista